to me i i think the the
the marketplace of ideas wins right if
they're out there saying like like what
you said the other day where they're
like we're gonna be great with women and
then people on twitter are like see
they've changed and they're like oh cool
so we're gonna be great yeah yeah but
but so so i can wear whatever i want no
no no no so i mean eventually
so it's i mean
let's just say what it is so you're
saying kind of like the the propaganda
will mold the the next generation into
being unreasonable is that the idea like
are you do you feel your kid's
generation is going to lack the the
processing skills to be able to see
extremism for what it is
yeah great guy we're going back and
forth we're trying to get a date for him
to come out here to be on the podcast
but in the interview i said let me ask
you a question do you think the more
shows we have on tv
that show whatever maybe has influence
over kids no i said okay while i'm
talking to him i said do you think the
more
we see lgbtq the more we see the
nickelodeon with the trans person coming
out and doing shows on kids do you think
that influences
kids to think they're gay or to want to
be gay he says no i said right well i'm
like maybe you're right maybe you're not
i don't know so i go online and i type
in
the increased percentage of population
being part of the lgbtq community i
don't know if you guys have seen this or
not
in the last 30 years it went from 1.1
percent to 2 to 3 percent to 5
today it's 5.4 percent why is it 5.4
percent did we all of a sudden have a
lot of people in the lgbtq community
last 20 years i don't know is it an
influence is it shows is it tv is it
somebody saying maybe i am it's the
questioning right it's like my friend
when we went to the nightclub at a gay
club in in in tennessee which was the
freaking best club i've ever been in my
life it was like the studio 54 of
tennessee underground place called
connection
it was happening if you went there
friday or saturday you had a monopoly
because it was with the bell button
there every night with the bell bottoms
you should see the clothes that was when
my hero was freaking uh tony monero i
mean that was my hero i was the middle
reason tony monero
and i don't know if you know who tony
monero is saturday my favorite baby
staying alive so so i'd go there and i
would do the whole thing and then one
day one guy comes up to him and he says
hey you know i like you and he and he
grabs him in the wrong places nowadays a
guy would do time but he might my guy's
like flipping out yeah because he's a
soldier and he says
you ever been with a man before
and he says what sub says he says i know
you were in the navy he says no
and
he says i like women he says he asks the
question
and he says how do you know you don't
like men if you've never been with one
so now that line has been asked for me
many times because this club i ran the
switch so i said dude i just know yeah
okay i like girls yeah i can tell you
it's gravity i like girls anyways
so we're driving back at 2 00 in the
morning no joke it's two o'clock in the
morning
my friend is like bro but how do i know
what is the matter with you buddy
he says but how do i know yeah how do i
know yeah maybe there's only one way to
i'm like are you seriously doing this to
yourself he says but you know do you
know that was the topic of discussion
you gotta know man unit we're doing
push-ups we're running six miles he's
asking at the end of chow hall but i
poor guy was conflicted he was
comfortable yeah that's the point i'm
trying to make to you with that i'm
confused now
which part of the hot dog do you like
better the meat of the bun which is the
when you get a hot dog is it the meat or
the bun that looks more appetizing you
know where this goes to you know where
this goes to think about
and and the reason why i'm convinced
with this is the following thing and
i'll bring you to something that's very
familiar to you that's porn
i'm glad you look to your left oh
finally
something i know
so
so uh we're trying to uh one of our
friends one of my friends armenian
friends from uh glendale uh said you
know what happened with brandy uh lori
brown bernie love she was upset she was
a fan of yours because you defended her
and but she was upset at everybody else
but nikki benz wants to come on okay
nikki bence wants to come and be a guest
on valuetainment so i said okay great so
we're conversations all this stuff
so she wants to be because believe it or
not she's a conservative she's a
conservative okay
so
go back and think about when you're
first time you watch porn so first time
you watch porn gerard
six seven i mean what was it for you it
was a sunny
afternoon
a january saturday today do not listen
to today's podcast let me prep you but
do you actually remember how old you
were how old were you the first time
i can be honest with you and you're
gonna think i'm a prude but probably at
a bachelor party for me and i'm not
joking i just didn't have access to yeah
in my 20s
yeah uh i could i can tell you i was i
don't know how old i was but i know i
was young enough
that you had to
physically come up and change the
television channels on the tv you were
determined okay i was a kid by the way
and and i i tried to click the i tried
to click
do you remember the t for people that
for people that don't know before the
internet existed it would be on tv and
it would be like all blacked out unless
you paid for the channel it would have
but you'd see like little snippets
especially there'd be like little
snippets that came out and i remember
being a kid being like whoa
what is this underground porn is what
you were watching was that my answer
here's a question for you here's a
question let's try to get the
nickelodeon here's a question for you
question for you did you watch porn
first or did you have sex first porn
okay all right so watch this so imagine
hard copy by the way like playboy hard
copy pornography i got you but what i'm
saying to you is if you watched porn
before you had sex you were somewhat
messed up okay so you know that yeah i
don't know if you've got it for sure so
do you guys understand where i'm going
100 man that's what i'm trying to tell
you yeah what i'm trying to tell you is
if you watched porn then you had sex
and let's just say the girl you had sex
with she'd been with others she was like
what the hell is the matter with yes i
mean you talk to any marriage counselor
that's destroying
that's what i'm saying so
when does your friend come in do i ask
her
i get so many i get questions from
spouses that say hey we have a porn
issue in the family we would like to see
how we can fix this porn issue because
everything is porn and porn is more
exciting than the real thing but men
have this thought pamela anderson talked
about it with her sons
she said i had to tell my boys what the
way people have sex in porn is not how
you have sex in bed that's not what it
is so where am i going with this if porn
made young boys think this is a certain
way of having sex that pleases people
just because it's a video that people
are screaming and then you go in their
bedroom they're like [ __ ] that's the
complete maybe some of the stuff but
some of the stuff it's not
then this goes back to
the taliban
[Laughter]
because it's because the people in
afghanistan
right now stay with me
how i took this story from a gay club to
porn back to this this is like a biden
speech came to life it's like
hell a lot we're gonna take come on man
the point i'm trying to make to you is
influence influence i'm telling you my
concern is influence you leave people
like this on the wrong person who
doesn't know what's gonna say but how do
you know but how do you know but how do
you maybe america does suck maybe we
don't maybe we are the ones that kill
maybe we are a terrible empire maybe we
are that's the part that you have to be
a little bit careful with that's the
part you have to be a little bit curious
there has to be reason again no pap
because people aren't getting on trash
floats and heading into the ocean to
escape people of america people aren't
clinging to their nails
you know what their vision is okay so
what's the kami's vision tell me
communist vision oh man what's communist
vision to eliminate greed to eliminate
billionaires to eliminate the rich to
eliminate the bourgeoisie i think that's
bs i think that their vision is their
self-empowerment under the guise of
humanitarianism
for sure but let me ask you a question
what's a socialist vision i i don't see
any difference between the time they're
slightly different but let's just say
it's pretty close to each other right
that's like 52nd avenue 53rd sure
socialism is just it's just the economic
engine behind capitalism i mean we know
that communism but but the taliban
you think they're you think their vision
is
controlling for you think that's what it
is yeah no that's not their vision it's
an interesting thing with the taliban
and all these freedom fighters
because all they care about is
eliminating authority and then what
happens when all you've done your whole
life is challenge authority and fight
authority then you become the authority
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]